before an ltr even starts the thing i
i want guys to understand and really
like internalize
is that as you guys call it dread i call
it you know pretty much she belongs to
the streets
unless proven otherwise and i i want all
the younger guys out here
you know to take a more contemporary
lens and understand
that women in 2020 are definitely
getting more action than you are
right they're more experienced than you
are from a sexual standpoint
and guys need to operate in that manner
and basically go into every single
relationship that you have with a girl
as if she's an expendable commodity and
i say that because we live in a
marketplace now
where if you look at a girl's phone it
is literally gonna like
change your perception of what's going
on here you're gonna see
crazy offer some sugar daddies uh for
thousands of dollars you're gonna see
offers to flyer out to foreign places on
instagram you're gonna see
comments and likes out to wooza
basically you're going to see more red
notifications
than a communism party you know what i'm
saying so
when you see this you need to understand
that since girls have so many options
your only real way to combat that is to
minimize any type of free attention how
do you do that well
put some respect on my name you do that
by not giving girls free attention
especially
in the digital media age and once girls
start passing those tests then you can
start
how do i say figuring out if she's
worthy of a relationship so i'm going to
tell you guys a quick story actually
that just happened to me last night
so i hope you use this on dates man i
hope you like it
there's a button on your phone from the
streets
dude i got i got all the sound boards
though it's always ready and i gotta i
just reprogrammed them too so i'm always
ready baby but
hey real quick guys i gotta get going so
i'll see you guys
um so guys so there's this girl that i
was seeing first
man like a little over a year or so kind
of like on and off
she would do some dumb i retract
attention whatever it may be right
so she started hitting me up recently
about a week and a half ago or whatever
right
and she wants to hang out so i put it to
the back burner because i'm dealing with
other girls so she's going to have to
basically weigh her turn in line you
know what i'm saying
so she said she wanted to come over uh
this was friday saturday friday night
and i was like no i got stuff to do
or thursday night excuse me i was like
nah i got stuff to do and she was like
oh well i want to come i was i want to
come i was like well whatever so and
this girl lives about two hours for me
she's up by west palm beach okay
she literally she drives right she
drives two hours and comes down here
right and she and i get a knock from my
security guy hey
uh this girl insert name here is
downstairs
and i'm like all right bring her up so
she comes up
i open up the door she looks at me she
walks in
and uh and she based you know whatever
we end up hooking up
and whatever but the point i'm trying to
make is rich always talks about genuine
burning desire right guys
and i'll tell you guys this even after
me not responding to her
and like just like doing my own thing
she drove two hours not knowing if she's
gonna be able to get inside
you know what i'm saying and when a girl
does things like that
you know what i'm saying and then the
next day she's helping me move into my
studio and put
moving boxes with me and everything like
that uh a couple blocks down
putting it in her car doing all these
things and acquiescing to what i need
done
that's when you start to put her through
the ringer again to see if she's worthy
and i tell guys this all the time man
the only way you're going to be able to
do that though where you don't respond
to her texts or
you know you're not thirsty or whatever
is by having other girls in place
competing man
and she knows that when she comes over
she sees hairs all over the place
all this other stuff she's like yeah
she's been having fun and i'm like yep
and i just like don't say nothing you
know what i'm saying so
and there's other things i do too to
like really get like chicks
uncomfortable as i always say
shout out to future b don't get too
comfortable and that's how you guys got
to operate with chicks
in 2020 man because quite frankly the
most attractive girls and everything
like that
they don't respect regular guys so the
only way you're gonna put respect on
your name is by
letting them know that they're
replaceable just like they treat you
because trust me
girls in 2020 treatment is expendable
commodities so that's all i want to say
on that little point right there
you